the jurogan experience it's so it's
weird man
it's like i wonder what's going on i
wonder if like there's a
thing that happens to a virus when it
goes through a number of hosts that it
sort of dies off
that it becomes weaker you know and
that's
part of herd immunity part of herd
immunity is a bunch of people develop
antibodies for it and also like
like the spanish flu like spanish flu
kind of just died off
like they and there's a thing about
fauci the other day said the virus
plateaued
the problem is like you don't know what
these [ __ ] how much of
what they tell you is political like how
much did they not tell us while trump is
in
office and how much are they telling us
now you know like in terms of
what's safe and what's not safe opening
businesses
what you can do for your health like
it's weird it's a it's such a [ __ ]
weird time
i guess the uk has a new version that's
more deadly not more contagious but more
deadly another new one yeah
just came out yesterday or today it's
like [ __ ] mixtapes
i know oh god yeah
and china's wide open yeah is it yeah or
that where the
the uh where it started they i saw this
whole thing where they're just like
nightclubs are all open everyone's like
going crazy i don't know about that if
that's real that might be propaganda you
might get there and the [ __ ]
everybody's welding inside their homes
you know yeah like who knows yeah but i
do know new zealand which has zero cases
at all like dan hooker
just fought on fight island and he can't
go home
he's from new zealand he can't go home
until he's quarantined until february
21st
so if that means maybe he if he goes
home he has to just sit
tight and can't go anywhere he can't
leave the house until february 21st
where he goes outside
but they have like very strict
quarantine loss when you get outside the
country
i think they have that in america too
right what is this oh yeah this is wuhan
look at that yeah but is that real yeah
this is well these pictures are just
like a
from the 20s just a couple days ago they
do kind of have masks some of them do
that one thing right she's she pulled
out her mouth to smell that dude look at
her
i had to smell you wow february 2020
no it's march i guess and here we are in
2021
and they're buck wild so what
what has happened they've gone through
it's gone through the city did they
they haven't been vaccinated right do
they have a vaccine
i wonder i wonder if or if everyone just
got it
i'll look through and see if they have a
conclusion in here finally people are
accepting the idea that this might have
come from a [ __ ] lab it's hilarious
i i brought it up once with brett
weinstein and
and some [ __ ] ridiculous
liberal smear website was saying that
i'm
promoting a dangerous conspiracy that it
emanated from a lab like the [ __ ] lab
is right there
it's not a conspiracy theory the lab's
right there like it's not like there's
we're making up the fact that there's a
level four lab
right there it's [ __ ] right there
there's two labs there by the way
like what are you talking about is that
a dangerous conspiracy
because they thought it was because of
trump because trump but trump was such a
problem
for so many people any theory that you
had
if trump was like anti-china you
couldn't say anything
that possibly would connect china to
making a mistake
that caused this virus to be released
you you would be a part of you'd be
alt-right catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience